hopefully resolve that legal issue over
the break call the witness back in miss
great please mrs gray
all right miss gray's back on the
witness stand go ahead mr shellhorn
thank you honor if we could just re-pull
up the breakout room please sure and
we'll resume
with where we we just left off
and again judge i'm referring to
exhibit for identification not evidence
s-171
ms gray we're just pulling that up in
front of you and if you recall i had
asked you
about line six seven seven eight
and i should back up um
you uh understand the
exhibit i know you don't have a physical
exhibit in front of you but it's been
marked as s 171 would be your text
messages between you and michael
barrisson
what are you asking me exactly
you understand that s 171 are the text
messages that were recovered from your
phone between you and michael barros
okay yes sir and you haven't reviewed
all of those before court today correct
no but you did look at some of them
before you came into court today i did
so i'm going to direct your attention to
line 6778
is that a text message from michael
barissone to you on february 17 2019
yes sir and what was the
uh
specific text of that text message
it's in column d um
how awesome i've had the experience i've
had that experience with horses too
horsemanship is in all we do if we see
it
next i'm going to direct you to and
we're going to pull this up lines 24 17
to 24 20. um when you were coaching
excuse me when when the defendant was
coaching you
as a writer
uh was did he have certain sayings or
things that he would say at times when
he was coaching you yes and were some of
those things that he would repeat on a
regular basis for sure and did some of
them almost become ingrained in in your
mind
yes yeah
and i'm directing you to line 24 17.
is that a text message from you to
michael barasone on may 18 2018
yes sir and do you ask him what are the
three things you never want to hear in
the arena yes
and then the second line where it says
he's this or he's that
i'm trying and what's the third is that
you asking him what those three things
are correct and on line 2418
did he respond to you he did and did he
tell you what the third thing was yes
what was that i know so if i direct your
attention down to line 2420 which is two
lines down
what did he say in that text message
i don't care what he or she is or likes
if you aren't trying why are you here
and if you knew you wouldn't have this
problem
and is that consistent with something or
three things that you never wanted to
hear a writer say in the arena yes sir
judge for the record can i have the date
set forth on
and the last questions that i wanted to
ask you on on this line uh would be
online 25
28. okay
uh and 25.29 are those two text messages
from the defendant michael barisson to
you yes sir and those are on may 23 2018
correct
and uh is the first one it's the part of
horsemanship most people don't get yes
sir
what did he say in the follow-up text
message to you
on line 2529
you want me to read it out loud yes okay
i have a limit on that nonsense horse
get a fucking hold of yourself
you will behave you will not threaten
you will not threaten nor endanger me
and you will do what i tell you or i
will beat your ass funny it's been
working perfectly a long long time
all right thank you
now in terms of how the work was split
uh at the farm on a day-to-day basis
when you were there what were your sort
of roles or responsibilities at the at
the farm
i did a lot of the writing
not as much of the teaching but most of
the writing
had some personal clients and personal
horses
and would
ride what i needed to when i needed to
type of thing and when you say that you
were in charge of or did a lot of the
riding what does that mean can you
explain that to me um the training of
the
horses oh were you paid to work there no
sir
did you pay the defendant anything to
board your horses there no sir how many
horses did you have living there for
example in august of 2019 i think eight
or nine
were there any other uh long-term
employees for the defendant
yes sir who was that justin hardin
and then some some kids that work for us
as working students that have been there
for a while
and can you explain to the jury who
justin hardin was and what his role at
the the barn was from your perspective
um
justin had been there a lot longer than
i had but he would be considered like an
assistant trainer he did a lot of the
teaching
to the ladies and also was a trainer of
the horses
do you know what the name of the
defendant's business was
michael bears and dressage
and are you aware whether he had a
website for that business i am yeah
with respect to the website uh
what is your recollection about what
some of the
different pages or sections of the
website were i think it showed both the
facilities
um florida and new jersey and then it
showed
picture and information on myself justin
and michael
judge i believe these items are marked
as
s73
excuse me judge s71
s72 hold on a second
so
71 s72
s73
s74
s75
and s76
i have no objection to these coming
intentions
all right
a 71 through s76 will be admitted into
evidence
gray i'm going to ask you if you could
first look at
what we'll pull up here is s
71
actually could i ask that you look at
first s-73
what does that 73 appear to be
maybe the home page
homepage of the website maybe
and you see a date in the top left
corner there
uh yes what's the date there august 8
2019.
and does this appear to be a fair and
accurate i guess uh screenshot or or
print out of the way the website looked
on the update
so you said you thought that this was
the
uh possibly the home page
what does it say under barista dressage
i don't recall
underneath that uh what did it say in
that next line and if you need to make a
little
um we are a full-service world-class
dressage boarding training and coaching
business with farms in new jersey and
florida
our team of grand prix dressage riders
produces horses to international levels
and we offer limited sales
and the picture there in the middle of
the the screen that would have been on
the website is what
the new jersey farm and is that the
clubhouse that you talked about earlier
correct
so if we look in the very middle of that
picture
uh you had indicated there was a like a
foyer with some coolers yes was that the
doorway that you would enter into
and where on this picture would the
office be that you
looked at pictures of
the far left window not the building on
the other side but in the front
structure the far left window
almost where that
column from the
overhang comes on
what was in the building
that is to the far left
it was a shop
workshop
scrolling down a little bit more
what is hawthorne hill
i think originally that was what john
lumber called the facility
who do you know john lombard today it
was a partner he was a partner with
michael arizona on the new jersey farm
and is it fair to say then i won't make
you read this whole thing but is this a
paragraph that was on the website that
would talk about some of the
uh facilities and what the amenities
were at the property correct
and is there also an address there
there is is that the same address as the
property that you were discussing
earlier yes sir
all right next i'm going to ask you if
you could look at s75
ns75 has that same logo in the center as
well as the same date in the top left
corner yes sir and it has that same
i guess description of the business
right under barristone dressage
as well
yes sir and if we scroll down on s75
who's that a picture of that's myself
just me
and
for the members of the jury who aren't
familiar with dressage uh what are you
wearing in that picture
i'm wearing the uniform that you compete
at fei levels so it's a
long shad bed we call it a shad valley
so long coat with tails and
competition helmet
and our white pants we ride in the shows
and then white gloves so like my
competition outfit
and if we scroll down a little bit more
and again i won't ask you i won't
embarrass you and ask you to read this
whole thing but is that uh your name as
well as a description of some of your
accomplishments and what you would offer
at the farm yes sir and your
next if i could uh direct your attention
to s76
does s76 have a date of august 7 2019 in
the top left corner it does and that's
the date of the shooting yes sir
and again has the same logo and and
language about the business in the
middle there
yes sir and as we scroll down
uh who is that a picture of michael
berezin
and again is he wearing the the common
uh attire that you would wear for an fbi
tournament yes or competition yes sir
and then does this webpage have michael
barisson's name as well as some other
information about his background and
some of his accomplishments in the
equestrian and dressage community
correct
and then the last
the last one i wanted to ask you about
at this point was s72
uh does that indicate a date of august
10 2019 it does
and if we scroll down
what is that a picture of the florida
farm
and that's the form that you indicated
that you would uh
train at when you were in florida with
the defendant correct now you indicated
that this stable was smaller than the
new jersey stable it is do you remember
approximately how many horses this
stable could accommodate um and this one
i think 14 i'm guessing as a guess
and again with this uh
with this website or this web page
rather there's the description of the
florida facilities and some of the other
amenities that are located there that's
correct
now during the summer of 2019
uh in in particular
did the defendant ever express any
concerns to you over the way that the
farm was running
yes
in general what were some of the uh
concerns he would complain of
i would say it was always like
management cleanliness
you know keeping things in order
i want to ask you a few follow-up
questions that that's about your own
horse ownership you indicated that in
august of 2019 you think maybe you owned
eight or nine horses i did um can horses
be expensive to buy
yes
what would be some of the factors that
may impact how expensive a horse is uh
the level of training uh competition
experience
talent quality age
and do people and i'll ask you
specifically about the dressage
community do people buy horses for
different reasons
for sure yes um what are some of the
reasons that you bought and owned eight
or nine horses
i bought my horses to develop
either to be competition horses or sail
horses
i'm assuming
that
purchasing the horse isn't where the
expenses end absolutely not what are
some of the ownership expenses that a
horse owner is responsible for
board
training if you if you go there
feed barrier vet
competition if you compete you can go on
and on attack
riding apparel
so uh tack is riding apparel
no writing girl will be like the stuff
you wear boots hat equipment and then
like the horse equipment and what's tack
tack is saddle bridle
blankets
boots you know everything that goes on
the horse
how about you just use the term farrier
for the members of the jury who don't
know what a farrier is what's that it's
the person that trims the horse's feet
the feet grow and they trim about every
four to six weeks and they put shoes on
or leave them barefoot
during the course of time that you were
working with the defendant and involved
in a romantic relationship with him did
you ever discuss anything about his his
reputation or did you ever see him do
any things to reflect on his reputation
can you elaborate
was his reputation important to him for
sure
and why was that
i think
[Music]
all um what's the nature of the
objection
on what grounds
how does she know why his
reputation is important for the reasons
clarify that i haven't rephrased the
question
you indicated that you ran a business
with the defendant
i worked with him work with him yes and
we just looked at a number of web pages
that uh
marketed the various properties that he
owned as well as himself and the
trainers who work there yes
did you ever make any observations of of
him and the way he would deal with
people that would indicate to you that
his reputation was important to him
i'm not sure how to answer that i think
um
in the in the horse industry your
reputation is is a lot
you know how you how you deal with
people and horses for sure
did you ever see him interact with other
people
coaching other people or training other
people besides yourself yes absolutely
and was the way that he interacted with
those people the same as how he
interacted and coached you or different
could be different and what would be an
example of it being different um
i think he was harder on me because of
our relationship and
his uh
desire to see me do well and
his belief in my abilities so
so i guess would the corollary to that
be that sometimes he was easier on other
people that he didn't coach on a regular
basis
yes
now during the times that you interacted
with him that you were working with him
that you were in a relationship with him
did you ever know anything about the
business that he was running
yes
for example did you know anything maybe
not specifics but you did you know
general things about the finances of the
business general things and can you tell
the jury what you knew
that it took a lot of money to run a
business about science
at times would he
indicate that to you or tell you that he
was
having issues in terms of cash flow
yes
and is it fair to say
that would be with relation to
having cash liquid available correct
do you recall approximately
how expensive it was or what the
expenses were on a monthly basis to run
the farm
i would guesstimate between 40 and 50
000 a month
and i'm going to direct your attention
to s 171
and i believe we i would ask for a
breakout room at this point judge
why
she
now you indicated that the defendant was
um
was married before you correct were you
aware of his finances related to the
divorce
not necessarily i mean i i've been
divorced so i know that finances usually
get split up
did he ever share anything with you
about how much money he had to pay
uh out in the divorce
i'm sure yes
so first i'm going to go back i'm going
to direct your attention to line
53-98
this is again s-171
this is line 53-98 is that a text
message from michael barissone to you
in november of 2018
that says how do you think i keep all
this going 40k a month i can't go to
sleep i have to be aware every day that
is correct
and then down
approximately six or seven more lines on
line 54.05
did he send you a text message
on that same day indicating the per
month expenses at the farm
yes he did and did he indicate the lease
for the new jersey farm was six thousand
dollars a month
mortgage florida three thousand feed
five thousand dollars shavings three
thousand dollars farrier three thousand
dollars property taxes three thousand
dollars
workers eight thousand dollars insurance
three thousand dollars utilities two
thousand dollars etc etc etc
yes sir
the other text message that i wanted to
direct your attention to was online 7270
are you aware of approximately when
michael barrasson's divorce with vera
kessel's became final
i am pretty sure it was december of
2018
okay and so this is a text message from
march 19 2019 is that correct
from michael barrasson yes
and did he say i got clipped 965k
hard to feel good
yes and was it your understanding or
does that refresh your memory
that he had paid approximately that
amount of money as a result of the
divorce
yes or was going to have to do that
now you indicated that uh the
maybe this is my words not yours but
that the
dressage community is somewhat
close-knit
absolutely um
are you aware of
an individual involved in the dressage
or
let's write that are you aware of an
individual involved in the equestrian
community named george morris i am and
do you know if the defendant knew judge
george morris personally i am aware of
that yes
did something happen to george morris on
august 5th 2019 yes do you know what
that was he had a lifetime safe sport
ban
and
was that uh newsworthy or noteworthy in
the questions yes
for several reasons
now you just mentioned safe sport can
you tell the jury what your
understanding of safe sport is um safe
sport is for all the olympic sports it's
something like all of us have to go
through either as a coach trainer
rider owner
it's a course you have to complete and
continuing education you have to stay up
up to date with about
um
all of the
basic moral values of dealing with
athletes children
everything from bullying to sexual abuse
all the things that have kind of gone on
in the past that have
brought us to this point
and um safe sport didn't exist when you
first started writing no absolutely not
so did it become something that when it
was instituted everyone knew about and
yeah yes it was a requirement to to
compete and be an active member
are you aware whether the defendant was
registered or licensed through safe
sport
i think in the beginning yes
what is the what is uscf
uh united states equestrian federation
and can you tell the jury what the role
of the united states equestrian
federation is
well we have two governing bodies we
have usdf and uscf
in order also in order to compete we
have to have
active memberships as as writer coach
owner um
they're they're governing bodies that um
we have to be members of in order to be
an active competitor
now were you aware of whether the
defendant michael barrissone knew people
at the the higher levels or at the
administrative levels of the uscf i am
aware of that
at some point did the defendant ask you
to gather information about lauren
cannon
yes
and did you have conversations with him
about contacting uscf uh in late july or
early august of 2019. yes sir
i'm going to direct your attention to s
171
line 93
38
is that a text message from michael
barissone to you on july 30th 2019.
it looks like me to michael
uh 93-38 i'm sorry
the wrong one was highlighted
um
michael to me yes
give me a reason what number is that
it's line 93 38
38
can you read that uh text message that
the defendant sent you on july 30th yes
um i need every single person who has
ever been screwed by lauren rob and the
dad barriers vets trainers every single
one
i'm going to get her a lifetime ban as a
competitor
and are the words every single person
entirely in capitals yes
did he then go on online 9342
approximately three text messages later
to repeat every single person all in
capitals yes
did you or the defendant at some point
make a complaint directly to uscf about
lauren canreck yes do you recall when
that was
july maybe in july sometime i don't
remember it would it be fair to say it
was around the same time
that that text message was sent oh what
was when was that set well that uh you
just identified that as july 30th 2009
and yes yeah
so i'm gonna
judge i'd like to ask for s 400
to be marked and entered into evidence
so i can show it to the witness and
display it to the jury
all right no objection
s4 it's 400 will be admitted into
evidence
and can be shown
to the witness and to the jurors thank
you honor
when you made the complaint to
you the united states equestrian
foundation how did you make that email
did you send the email or did someone
else
i don't remember maybe both of us
actually
did you at any point ever uh collect
materials and send them in the in the
regular mail or ups i did
and what specifically did you send them
um
lots and lots of information that we
gathered on lauren canaric
and um i'm going to show you what's been
marked as s
400.
does s 400 appear to be a receipt from
the ups
store
uh dated in the top left tuesday august
6 2019 yes sir
and who is the sender
myself
who is the recipient sonya keating
what is your understanding or who do you
know sonia keating today
i think she was the main contact for
your safe sport
where did you get her name as a contact
to send this to i don't recall
did the defendant give it to you
i don't recall
all right we'll scroll down uh
to the second page of s 400
ss 400.
and in the top left is that a copy of
the receipt
uh from the ups store yes and does that
indicate you sent it from the chester
ups store on august 6 2019 at 1 11 pm
yes sir
scrolling down a little bit more uh it
indicates i think
correct me if i'm wrong that you bought
a box while you were there to ship the
materials in apparently yes
where it says 8.5 by 11 copies qty 756.
what does that mean to you a quantity of
756 pages
and
would that be the does that sound
approximately like the number of pages
that you would have sent as part of this
package yes you have safe sport yes
okay now i think you had indicated
before that you would train at the
florida farm in the winter months and
then come north to new jersey to train
during the summer season correct
approximately
approximately when did the summer season
run from
april or may to
november
so in august of 2019 were you here at
the new jersey farm correct
that summer when you moved here in
approximately april may where were you
living
don't recall at the the very first where
we were living it was at the barn in the
barn apartment or we went straight to
the house i don't recall
but at some point that summer were you
living in the house absolutely yes and
is that when you referenced earlier that
you were also living in the house at the
same time as robin yes correct
you also i think indicated that justin
hardin had previously lived in the
second floor but that in the summer of
2019 robin lord we're looking at that's
correct what was the reason for the the
change in living
situation
honestly i can't answer that other than
arrangements were made for her to move
in and justin to move out
well let me ask you did anything happen
to the house
are you aware of anything happening to
the house
at some point during the winter of 2018
2018.
what was that there was a pipe that
burst in the top floor and
the kitchen that belonged to justin
harden and the water ran through all
floors of the house
and did you actually see some of the
damage at some point that had been done
by the water yes
what floors was that too
from what i understand it started in the
upstairs kitchen and then the ground
floor was
the whole kitchen area and a little bit
into the dining room was
needed a full renovation and down into
the basement as well
and the basement is where you indicated
that the working students would usually
live correct
were any of them able to live there
during the summer of 2019 no
and when you moved back into the house
in the summer of 2019 what floor of the
house were you living on the ground
floor what was the condition or state of
that floor
it was needed a full renovation
now directing your attention to lauren
canorac and rob goodwin do you recall
when you first met them approximately
approximately yes
in the winter
in florida
of 2018.
and did they then come back to new
jersey and live lauren live and train uh
in new jersey in the summer of 2018.
i don't recall i think i think that she
came as a client but i think loved maybe
elsewhere at the time
now what was the nature of your
involvement with lauren kanarek from a
business or a working perspective when
she first came to barriston dressage
um
i taught her here and there
and at some point did that change
in what way
did the defendant ever ask you to do
anything with respect to training or
coaching or in canary
yes when was that
um i helped her even when she first came
i taught her some in florida
um
[Music]
and then mostly it was justin and then i
helped her some in the summer of 2019.
how did that go
really bad
did you express that to the defendant
yes
what was his response
um
i'm not really sure how to answer that
other than
i i wasn't able to deal with it anymore
so he was
i asked him the teacher
did you have any professional
relationship with rob goodwin
only via the horses and being around in
the barn
i mean did you ever coach him train him
with him no
what would you describe your your
personal or social relationship like
with them when they first came to the
barn in florida
when they first came to work with
michael barrasson and barriston dressage
how would you describe your personal or
social relationship with them
non-existent
so you had no interaction with them at
the beginning of their not really i mean
i told her maybe a handful of times the
first time first season in florida
but no social relationship
did you ever have a social relationship
with them i would say no
what was what was your understanding or
knowledge just what you were aware of of
the working agreement or the
professional agreement between lauren
kanarek and the defendant
that i never really knew
did you ever have any observation did
you know why she was at the farm oh
absolutely yes what was she doing at the
farm to
work on her riding and developer horses
progress as a writer and did she come
there to work with michael barrasson
with you with justin harding there's
michael bearson
did you ever observe them working
together yes do you know if she had any
horses at the bar she did do you know
approximately how many um the number
grew um maybe four
at one time
are you aware if she was paying any
money to michael barassone to board the
horses train the horses or get coach
there yes
summer of 19 whether it was at the new
jersey summer
2018. yeah
19 was at the house
and
you indicated that they were living in
the farmhouse that's correct
now we just looked at those uh
some of those text messages between you
and michael barissone as well as the
receipt from the ups store
is it fair to say
or or would you characterize
things between yourself and michael and
rob and lauren at that time as good or
bad
the whole environment was really bad
objective time frame yes we repeat that
question
i'll re-ask you judges rephrase then all
right withdrawn and rephrase please
by july of 2019
how would you describe the relationship
between yourself and michael barristone
with lauren canareck and rob goodman
2019 yes
the environment and the stable
and around them was really unhealthy and
toxic
at some point did michael barrasson send
you a text message telling you that he
would make things miserable for them to
say
i think that we you and i have talked
about that but i don't necessarily
recall well let me show you the text
message
and this is on s171 judge line
zero eight zero
is line nine zero eight zero a text
message from michael barrasson to you on
july 13 2019 yes sir
and did he text you i will just make it
so miserable to be here that they will
beg to go elsewhere watch me this i am
very very good at yes
is it fair to say that during the course
of july 2019 and august 2019 there were
conversations between you and the
defendant
about ways to get rid of lauren canorack
and rob goodman yes to get them off the
farm yes
now you mentioned that you were living
in the farmhouse with michael barason
and that lauren and rob were living
upstairs yes at some point that summer
do you recall if you moved out of the
farmhouse we did you remember
approximately when that was
end of july
and where did you go
up to the clubhouse
club
at times during
the beginning of august 2019 when you
were living up at the clubhouse at this
point
did other people come to stay at the
farm
they did you recall who some of those
people may have been my father
my son was there at some point
ruth cox
mary defranco
some of the kids were there their
parents type of thing
and so ruth cox for example who is ruth
cox
ruth is
a person that i owned a horse with and
michael owned a horse with i actually
had two horses with she was a partner
and a friend and a client and how
frequently would you would you say that
she would come to the box quite often
i'm going to show you what's uh
line 9350
on s171
and if you is that uh a text message
from michael barrasson to you on august
3rd 2019. yes
did he tell you i need people here
adults granddad i told ruth she can't
leave they will be broken by force of
numbers that is correct
and that was after you had moved out of
the farmhouse and up to the clubhouse
that's correct
and i forget i think
you had said that it was very the things
up there were very toxic or something to
that effect
that's an understatement
now are you aware in the beginning of
august 2019
so after you move out of the
farmhouse on about july 30th you're
living in the clubhouse
for those first couple of days in august
of 2019 are you aware of whether anyone
explicitly told lauren and rob to leave
the problem
at some point yes it was said through
um
i think i actually said it at one point
it was set through an attorney in a
meeting
so yes
are you aware of whether michael
barisson ever told him to leave
i'm not aware of that
i'm going to direct your attention to
line 9 3 6 4
and nine three six five okay is 9364
a text message from you to michael
barrasson on august 3rd 2019 yes
and did you ask him why can we not say
to lauren and rob and the father because
still no one actually has we are
evicting you you must leave no one has
said it that's correct and is his
response to you online 9365
monday morning
yes that's correct
moving down several more lines to line
93 71.
is that another text message from later
that day on august 3rd 2019
yes is that a text message sent from
michael barrisson to you at 7 11 pm
yes and does he say
let the calm stay give the man
in meeting with her in that room uh was
the door open or closed closed was
anyone else in that room
when you were having substantive
conversations with her about why she was
there yeah
did anyone ever interrupt you yes who is
that michael barrison do you recall how
many times he interrupted you
three maybe
and without getting into specifically
what the caseworker may have said
uh after she told him something what did
he do
would he stay in the room or leave oh he
would leave
at some point did he come back into the
room and
ask you to leave the room yes
where did you go after you left the room
we went to the room adjacent to the
office
and did that have a door on it it did
were you able to see
uh where michael barrisson went or what
he did after he asked you to leave the
office no
what were your observations of his
demeanor at the time that the caseworker
arrived
terrified
horrified um
and panic um
despondent i mean just completely
obsessed
did you see him um at that point running
around the clubhouse or the barn at all
no did he raise his voice or yell or
scream or anything at that point no not
that i'm more of
now at some point did you become aware
that there were police at 411 west mill
road on august 7th yes
do you recall how you became aware of
that
um
i think i'd come out of the office and
my father was actually walking up the
driveway
so he told me do you have any personal
knowledge of what happened at the
farmhouse that after
this great
you indicated that your status is
professional correct correct
what is lord catrack's
addiction
as far as i know adult amateur
and
what is the quality of her writing
ability
objection
what's the basis for the objection i
think there could be a foundation sorry
there could be a foundation laid but i
don't think there's any foundation for
that question to be asked
i think it also calls for opinion but
depending on the nature of the
foundation she's the trainer
i don't know
i'll agree with your characterization
over an extended period of time
but she did indicate that um
at points um
she worked with
um
miss
canorack prior to the defendant so
i don't find a question objectionable
i'm not sure of the relevance but
i'll allow council some wheat uh leeway
in that regard
what's lauren canorex riding ability
she actually has quite a bit of ability
and and
capability to be a great rider
but she rides as an amateur if that's
what you're asking
and uh do you consider yourself a better
writer more accomplished writer than she
i wouldn't say a better writer it's you
don't even really have to have talent if
you want to put the time in and work on
getting better i have um
competed more and have more
like accolades because i've been doing
it a long time but
the average person can learn to ride if
they want to put the time and effort
right
did warren cataract put the time in
based on your observations of her not
necessarily
did she always show up
when she was scheduled to ride most of
the time not
did she cause disruption within the
stable for the dressage business
while she was there
a lot of times yes
so
the prosecutor asked you specific
questions about the farm house the three
different living areas
uh directing your attention to july of
2019
that was after there was a flood correct
correct
and
where was michael barrasso when that
flood occurred
in florida
with you
yes
was anyone living in the house at that
time to your knowledge
not to my knowledge now
in the
summer of 2019
was the house under construction
yes
where you and michael
were living on the main floor of that uh
farmhouse
was that
partially uh
um
being
renovated
it was
i don't think it had started yet but it
was
gutted and empty
it was gutted there was no insulation
could you hear the tenants
above you yes
lauren and robert goodwin correct
correct
and
did there become a problem
with them living above you
yes
what was the problem
um
is that because
do you think he believed that you had
the talent to accomplish great things in
your sport i do
and
would you agree with me that he didn't
push lauren cataract
as hard as you correct
absolutely not
did he believe that she did not have the
talent or the drive objection to do that
yeah um
i think that's objectionable about what
was in mr barrison so
question will be stricken move on
now
he indicated on directive that michael
barrasson's reputation
means a lot to him correct
correct
does your reputation mean a lot to you
sure
and was your reputation attacked by
lauren cataract and robert goodwin
yes
did they basically do the same thing
to you
that they were doing to michael barrison
hold on a sec
let me see that sidebar
now
you indicated that michael barrisson's
reputation is important to him correct
correct
do you know any
other
professional athlete or
dressage
whose reputation is not important to
them
no sir
now
do you have personal information with
regards to lauren cataract
attacking
michael varus's reputation yes
and again
the prosecutor brought out that you
you sent
750 some pages
to safe sport
with respect to a complaint
that you made against lauren cameron
correct
correct
what was in those
750 pages that the prosecutor
brought out indicated i mean generally
speaking
generally speaking
all of the horrible things that she had
said about us um and had said to other
people
horrible threats and
abuse on social media
and you
specifically sent the actual post with
her words to them correct correct
you said social media posts with regards
to
threats that were made against you and
michael barrasso correct correct
and michael barrison saw these
threats on social media correct correct
how do you know that
we would look at them together okay
next question and could you tell me what
effect what impact
did those social media posts have on
michael
barrasso
we both we were terrified
of what it was building to and what was
coming next he was he was absolutely
petrified and terrified
and
did you or he do anything
with regards to hiring certain people to
try to protect yourself
we did
isn't the fact that
a private security guard was hired to
sit
at the top of the hill in front of the
stables
to guard the stables and the people
inside that's correct
were you concerned about just your
or your staff's personal safety or the
safety of the horses in the stable
both
did any of the
clients
take precautions with regards to
protecting their horses based on these
social media posts yes sir
what did they do
slept in front of the horse's stalls and
some of the ladies were super concerned
about
the status and the barn
and what was the threats being made
it's your testimony that
grown
women would actually sleep
in front of the horse stables correct
because they were concerned for their
own horse's safety correct and can you
tell me what effect did you observe that
have on michael barista
i mean everything just was materializing
more and more every day
that she was doing and
he was absolutely unraveling
now
was a private investigator hired to do a
complete background check
on lauren cataract and robert goodwin
correct
is that one of the things that you sent
to
safesport uh yes i think so yes
and
i'm not asking you what was in that
can you tell me what impact that had on
michael barrisson when he got that
background check on both of those people
we were horrified these people were
living on our property
and we're unaware of these things
were you afraid of them i was yes was
michael barason terrified of them yes
sir
now let's talk about his business for a
second
takes a lot of money to run a course
statement correct correct
prosecutor
showed you some breakdown that michael
had sent you correct correct
um did michael
usually always make his payments
and keep things afloat always and was
was it a struggle at times like it is
for everyone else all right mr blinkist
everyone else isn't on trial here so
keep your questions and comments to the
issues in this case please
you indicated that michael barrisson
always paid his bills correct correct
irrespective of a cash flow problem
you're also aware of the fact because
you're familiar with his business
and his personal finances that he had
millions of dollars worth of assets
correct correct
he owns the farm in florida free and
clear correct correct he owns a number
of horses which could be worth close to
a million dollars correct correct
and he has some investment accounts
correct correct
and even though
at times
it was a struggle to keep all the bills
paid
at some point in time
he told lauren cataract
objection
we discussed this at the break your
honor
tears i'm sorry to leave the property
well hold on a second hold on a second
let me see you at sidebar
now the prosecutor uh
asked you questions with regards to a
text like no one officially
told lauren cataract
to leave remember that text
yes sir isn't it a fact that numerous
people
had told cataract
it's time to leave judge
again mr blankison
i just ruled on that
just i thought i was referring to
response to that text
judge i'll move on if you get look the
text message was written if you want to
refer to the text message that's fine
but
i ruled it it's improper to go outside
of what this witness testified to in the
text message
with regards to that text it says that
no one officially told her to leave
correct correct
isn't it a fact that unofficially
numerous people told
her to leave
you know what ladies and gentlemen let's
take our lunch break now and i'll
resolve this legal issue once and for
all all right please don't talk about
the case we'll resume at um
try to get back at around 1 20 so
everyone's assembled we can start at 1
30. all right thank you all please don't
discuss the case
you